when he hired a Epstein to become a  professor teaching mathematics this is a  guy that's never had a degree before  right like Epstein never got it he would  have not been eligible as I understand  it to even teach in public school in New  York how does that make any sense for  him to get a job even though he's never  had a degree before right so Donald Barr  apparently hired unconventional teachers  and was known for this right but he  actually left by the time Epstein  started hiring decisions were apparently  made in the spring in that summer Donald  Barr left after having made those hiring  decisions so during most of Epstein's  time there it was another Headmaster and  from what I understand Donald Barr's  him leaving the Dalton school was rather  acrimonious like he was sort of forced  out it seems by angry parents and some  angry teachers